efectivamente esta habitación viene a
darse como una primera prueba de fuego
de las disciplinas laborales que se
incorporaron dentro de la renovación del
tratado de libre comercio entre méxico
estados unidos y canadá es
representativo por dos razones la
primera porque en eeuu recientemente
existieron críticas muy profundas a las
prácticas sindicales en mexico se les
atribuía a dichas prácticas no solamente
no defender los derechos de los
trabajadores sino además también el
otorgar a méxico una competitividad
artificial al mantener los salarios
artificialmente bajos entonces sin duda
esto creo que viene a ser primero una
reivindicación de ese de esa crítica que
siempre se tuvo en eeuu hacia méxico y
segundo pues bueno yo creo que también
es importante porque en méxico el año
anterior en el 2000 hace dos años ya era
en 2019 entró en vigor una reforma
laboral que estaba es sin duda la más
progresista que se ha incorporado dentro
de nuestro país entonces bueno esto por
una parte viene a ser una revalidación
de los compromisos de méxico-estados
unidos-canadá con lo que eso implica
para nuestra zona económica y segundo
pues bueno ver si la reforma laboral en
méxico también funciona como se debe
ahora juan esta votación marca un antes
y un después en las diferencias que hay
entre el dtm que con respecto al
anterior tratado del tlcan que incluye
el nuevo timo que no tenía el anterior y
que tiene también en tensiones entre
méxico y eeuu
bueno sin duda primero estos temas que
ya estamos hablando del laboral de
derechos laborales hay otro capítulo
similar pero para cuestiones ambientales
que básicamente tienen los mismos
objetivos el que se cuide el medio
ambiente que no se degrade a través de
las prácticas comerciales hay también un
mayor requerimiento de uso de insumos de
la región reglas de origen en el largo
técnico lo cual implica como recordarás
tú aquellos debates o aquellas críticas
que sea bonachón que requiere que se
compren más productos de la región y
menos de otras de otras partes creo que
tal vez lo más importante es que a
diferencia del tratado anterior este
nuevo acuerdo incluye una cláusula de
reducción
para cada seis años para ver qué cambios
se le tiene que ser tratado y que se
mantenga vigente por lo que entiendo
esto significa entonces que había un
vacío un vacío en el anterior acuerdo en
cuanto a los derechos de los
trabajadores no es así es correcto entre
sí y otros temas como los que acabo de
mencionar laboral la revisión etcétera
yo no lo atribuía necesariamente a que
fue algo deliberado tenemos que
recordarle a la audiencia que el tratado
anterior data de 1994 entonces bueno en
aquel momento la concepción del comercio
y de los derechos laborales era
diferente incluso hay muchas cosas en el
tratado actual que antes simplemente no
existían como el comercio electrónico en
1994 el internet no se había todavía
magnificado y es por eso que el nuevo
tratado tiene todos estos nuevos
capítulos digamos que es una
actualización en nuestros tiempos que
estamos viviendo -juan carlos gracias
por su tiempo y por estar con nosotros
en france 24 que tenga usted un feliz
resto del día